hallo Kassandra ich habe eine ja eine
Frage an dich und zwar wie kamst du
eigentlich auf den Namen deines Albums
mir so nah ja würde mich echt mal
interessieren weil hat ja manchmal auch
so so eine kleine hintergeschichte und
ja das war meine Frage und den sing ist
echt cool
und ja heute und so und bye
wie süß hab Herzchen
gekriegt okay wie kam ich auf den Titel
mir so nah es war sehr schwierig wir
haben erst gedacht wir nehmen Titel für
die
Platte von von eines der Songs um das
wiederzug geben hat nichts richtig
gezogen man braucht ja trotzdem eine
Aussage es muss es muss mich
reflektieren aber es muss euch ja auch
ergreifen so was nimt man da als Titel
leben
ja gebt
alles das überlassen wir dann der Single
dass die das alleine trägt für die
Platte muss ich sagen da kam dann auch
mein Management drauf Seku vielen Dank
mir so nah weil es einfach tatsächlich
das reflektiert also die Stücke selber
sind mir sehr nah sind auch sehr aktuell
was mein Leben betrifft es ist nicht so
dass ich das jetzt vor dem Jahr
geschrieben habe und jetzt bin ich nicht
mehr in diesem Bereich meines Lebens in
diesem Ablauf und deswegen haben wir uns
dann für mir so n entschieden
tatsächlich
genauso ist also das was ihr auf der
Platte hört das passiert gerade jetzt
bei mir deswegen mir so
nach